và nếu như vào môi trường cho biết chính xe cao điểm chiến mê ngày đêm,
là sạch giữ liệu đã đại đại đại đường dự kết khỏi quan trọng.
Đáng chú ý là việc thống nhất phần về mùi dung chung trên tảng Quốc,
tạo nên tàn cho ý thống khoảng lý đa đại đồng bộ từ chung hơn đến liệu phương.
Để đây đã sạch xuất được hơi sống mới móc chữ thử đất.
Chúng đau có 1,5 tư chục thử,
cơ bản đặt tư chí đúng đủ sạch.
Tuy nhiên, tư chí sống, tất cả mẹp theo thời gian thử,
vẫn chưa được đánh giá đầy đồng.
Hẹn vẫn còn hơn 3,5 tư đất cần tiếp tục đau đạt,
cập nhé thông tin và khoảng 1,5 tư ở chứ được đưa vào hệ thống.
Mùa số đề phương có tỷ lệ đại đại đại đại đại đại đại đại đất.
Bộ nếu màu chừng cho biết thêm,
mùa tư chung nó mang in thương tra mình sấu là cơ bản hoàn thành đau đạt,
lập bản đồ địa chính đăng ký đất đai,
là bầu sức tàn chính và xây dựng hoàn thiện cơ sử hệ khu sai,
về đất đai chính phản vì tăng Quốc,
bà đàn phụ kiến tạm bộ thử đất,
bản hành thống nhất đồng bộ phụ vụ yệu quả khoảng 1,5 tư,
và cùng cấp dịch vụ không,
bộ cùng nhé mạnh yêu cầu đưa sự liệu vào phản hành,
ngay sau khi xây dựng đồng thời gian thương xuyen liên tục theo thời gian thật.
Chứ cật giật phương cần giả sóa đối khắp thông tin,
hồi sự dụng đất, mới cơ sử dụng lệ của sai về dân cơ,
sử lý chịt đề các trường giúp sai là chứa ra đệnh trủ dự dụng hoàn hồ sơ,
chưa hoàn thiện pháp liy.